hey guys welcome back to another session
by simply learn
in this video we will discuss how to
make a tic-tac-toe game both in c plus
and in javascript
this tic-tac-toe game is pretty famous
and is often played by many in their
childhood in this game two players one
by one mark cross and zeros in a three
cross three grid
the objective of each player is to pair
3 marks in a row column or in a diagonal
manner before the other player
the player who succeeds in doing so wins
the game
so let's create this tic-tac-toe game in
c plus and then in javascript
so first of all
we have to make the structure of
tic-tac-toe game
and the structure of tic-tac-toe is like
this
these are the empty spaces and we have
to mark these empty spaces with crosses
and zeros
and now these are
column numbers and row numbers which
will help us in adding alphabets to
these empty spaces
so first of all we have to create this
structure so let's go ahead to our
visual studio code
so first of all let's name this
game dot cpp
we'll save it
so now let's start with hash include
iostream
now we'll write using namespace standard
now before making the structure we have
to create an array a multi-dimensional
array or we can say a two-dimension
array
so we'll write into main and inside int
main first of all we'll declare that
array and initialize
some elements
all right
let's say the name of the array is space
three rows and three columns we want
okay so let's say the elements are
zero zero
zero one
zero two
okay now
the second row the elements are
1 0
1 1
1 2
in the third row the elements are
2 0
to 1
to 2
so these are the elements i have added
these elements because these are
collectively the rows and column numbers
of the spaces
as you can see
0 0 0 1 0 2 1 0 1 1 1 2 2 0 2 1 2 2 so
these are those elements i have added
these are actually the positions of the
empty spaces
now
we will take the input of the number of
players
as their name
for example enter the name of first
player and enter the name of second
player so for that we have to create a
string first of all
let's say string n1
and string n2 because there are two
players
now we'll display a message that enter
the name of the first player let's say
enter the name
we missed writing e
okay enter the name
of the
first
player
okay
let's add slash in
all right
now let's take the input we'll write
get line
c in comma
and one
which is the name of the
string now we'll do same for the other
one
enter
the name of the
second
player
now again we'll write get line
c in comma
and two
now just in order to make it look good
will write
n1 that is the name of the first string
or the name of the first player
is
player 1
so
he
or she
will play first
okay now we'll write slash n
now we'll do same for the player two
we'll simply copy this
and paste it
and now
all right
let's change this player 2 and
we'll play second
okay
now we have to make the structure of the
tic-tac-toe game
that is this kind of a structure we have
to make
so let's go ahead and create this
okay
we have to create two straight lines so
we can do like this
and make sure to write slash n
in the end
now we can do same for the second line
because the two lines are pretty long
enough so we can copy and paste
it will save our time and we can do
again
now we have to create a horizontal line
as well
for that let's say
c out
and
we can create this horizontal line by
using underscore
we'll give it a shot
and
we can do it like this
so that
it matches with the upper line
all right
now
we can
write slash n
and we can do
copy these two
and we can again paste
and then this
horizontal line
you can copy basically we have to create
a structure
so
it is good if you can do it in a fast
way
or an easy way
all right but the
18 and 19 line seems to be extra so yeah
we can remove that
so that
let's make it more symmetrical
let's add some more underscores
here as well
make it like this
all right now it is looking pretty much
symmetrical
let's remove this line
yeah it is looking good now
now all we need to do is to add the
elements of the multi-dimensional array
that is space array
to these empty spaces like we have to
add element on each and every empty
space
so as you can see this is the zero zero
that is zero throw and zero column this
is zero throw and first column this is
zero through and second column and
similarly all of these
so that is why we have created these
kind of elements so yeah we can also
change these elements let's create them
one
two let's make it simple
seven
eight
and nine
so yeah all we need to do is to add
these elements to these empty spaces
our main intent behind adding these
elements to these empty spaces is
whenever we click a particular element
or digit like let's say 2 or 3 then the
mark of 0 or x should be placed at that
particular position
so let's do it
and for that we have to do it like this
write c out
and
inside c out
we'll write the name of the array
with the position of it
of a particular element
so this is the position of the first
element that is one
and after that
we'll do it like this
okay so this is the vertical line
and
then again we have to
right
the position for the second element
that is 0
1
this element is 2
and once we have
wrote this then
we can enclose it
in the bracket
all right
now
the second vertical line
and we'll do same for the third one
right space
0
2 that is the third element that is 3
now let's enclose it
in double quotes
all right
yeah
slash n
semicolon
now let's fix it
now it's fine
now we have to do the same for the
second row and the third row
so
all we need to do is to copy this
and we'll add
over here
and
over here as well
instead of writing this whole code we
can simply copy paste and now all we
need to do is to just change the row
number and the column number so as you
can see this is the first this is the
second and this is the third element so
we'll do same for the other elements so
this is the fourth element
so this position is
1 0
and this position is 1 1
this position is 1
2
and this is a
second zero position
this is two 1 position
and this is
this is position 2 2
that is the last position
so this is the thing
so we can check if it is looking good or
not
i'm pretty sure that is not fully ready
yet but yeah we can check
so we'll save it by pressing ctrl and s
now we'll try to run this
so as we can see enter the name of the
first player so let's say the name of
the first player is sam
and this name of second player is
mario
and yeah so this is
our output
but it is not looking good as its
alignment is not good
which i was sure
so we have to make some changes
we have to adjust a bit
this was the vertical line and this was
the second vertical line
so let's make some changes and
let's see if it is looking good or not
sam
and mario again
it is better than earlier but as you can
see this
one is not underneath this one
that is the vertical line
is not underneath the previous vertical
line and same for the sixth same for the
ninth
so we'll have to adjust this
and it's pretty easy we can do that
yeah now let's save it again
and let's hope it runs this time
enter the first name we have to enter
let's add mario first this time
same the second time
yeah it is looking good now as you can
see
it is symmetrical and
positions are also filled one two three
four five six seven eight nine these are
those elements
now all we need to do is to
make this structure as if a person that
is the player
will click a particular digit that is
one two three four five six or seven
eight nine then that mark that is
zero or cross will be added to that
particular position
and also we haven't noticed that this
mario is player 1 mario's play 2 is
wrong
that is we have we have to write n2 over
here so by mistake
we have wrote n1 and
and we can add one space over here as
well
so yeah the rest is good
now all we need to do is to create some
functions
but before that
let's make it right
yeah
now let's make this all code inside a
function so let's say
let's move this into main we'll do that
later
let's create this code inside a function
let's say the name of the function is
function1
okay
all right
so this is our function and let's create
all these variables outside the function
so that it can be
global variables
and we also take this array
we'll
copy it
and paste it over here
all right
and we can remove it from here
yeah so we have declared it globally and
we'll do the same for the variables that
is row
and another variable that is column
because we know that
in a two dimensional area there must be
rows and columns
so we'll write
column
all right so these are the global
variables
so now let's go ahead and create
function two
for that
let's say we'll write void
function
2
now inside this function
we will check for any invalid value and
we'll make sure that it is not there
but before that we will
create a variable digit
so that we can take the input from the
user
so we'll write
and digit this is the variable
now after that
we'll write
so here we will write if the value of
token that is the variable that we will
now create is equal to x then we will
take the input from the first player and
then we'll take the input from the
second player
so
before that we have to create a variable
token
we'll write here
this variable is of corrected type
character
token
let's
initialize it with cross
or x
all right
now
here we will write
if
value of token
equals equals
cross
then we'll
write n1
that is the variable name
enter please enter we'll write please
enter
after that
we'll take the input
that is the variable digit
now we will do same for player 2 that is
n2
so we can copy this
and we can paste it
all we need to change is
we can make it
zero
and
make it n2 so it will display
and 2 that is player 2 please enter
and then the player 2 will enter the
digit
now we have to check these digits for
each and every column and rows one by
one
and also we have to make sure that there
is not any invalid value
so for that
we'll write
if
digit value is
one
that is the number entered by the player
is one
that is the first place or the first
space
then
it would be
row
equals 0
and
column
equals 0
that is the first place
just to clarify here we are talking
about this position that is zeroth row
and zeroth column
after that we'll do it for zero throw in
first column then zero throw and second
column and similarly we'll do for all of
these positions
okay now we have to repeat this code
we have to just change this digit value
to 2 3 4 5 6 up to 9 because there are 9
spaces
and we have to change the rows and
columns value so instead of writing it
again and again we can just copy and
paste it
we'll copy
and
i will paste
and we'll do it for
nine times three
all right now all we need to do is to
change these values
if the value of the digit is 2 that is
entered by the user for the player
then
the value will go to
zero throw
and first column
with the values three
then zero throw second column
or third column because we are starting
from zero so that is why we are talking
like this
now if the value of digit is four
then zero throw
and
then first row sorry
first row
and
0th column
then
if the value is five
then first row
and
first column
if the value is six
first row
and second column
if the value is seven
then
second
row
zeroth column that is right
the value of digit
eight
we'll write eight
and
the value would be
row 0
row 2
and column 1
here digit is 9.
so row would be 2
and column would be 2.
after that in else we can write
if the case is invalid
we will print
invalid
all right
we can write endl after that
now this condition else means
if the value entered by the player is
any other value than the values at the
empty spaces that is from 1 to 9 then
that case would be an invalid case so
that is why here we have written invalid
now after that
we have to write an if condition
so first of all i'll write the if
condition because it's pretty long and
after that i'll explain it to you
so we'll start with if
the value of token
is
[Music]
cross
[Music]
and
space array
that is row and here we'll write
column
not equal
to x that means
that means if x is not there at a
particular position
and
similarly we'll write four
the
zero
you will write
column
i will write row
if i take particular position
there is no zero as well
so
that means
that is a unused place
so inside this we'll write
space
row
column
x
or cross
token
equals
zero
okay so we have wrote this and now i'll
explain you this part
so here we are checking if there is any
unused space which is left in the
structure to fill
so what we are doing is if the value of
token is x that means player 1 turn is
there and at a particular place there is
not x and not 0 as well so player 1's
value x would be assigned there as we
can see in line 96 after that player 2
turn is there so we have assigned the
value 0 to the token that is player 2's
value
after this we have to use
else if statement and do the same for
player 2 as well
all right
now we'll write else if
and we'll do
the same we can copy it and paste it
over here
we need to do minor changes
we have to change it to zero
and
this one would be same this means if
player 2 turn is there
then if the value is not x at a
particular place and neither it is 0 at
a particular place then that particular
place is empty or unused
so
we will assign zero at that place
because now the turn is of player two
okay we can copy paste it as well
because the code is same
here would be 0
and the token would be x or cross
after this we have to write the else
block
and inside that block we have to call
the function again so that we can play
it again
so
all we need to do is we will print
there is no
empty space
all right
we can use
and l
we have to call this function the name
of the function is function2
you write function2
so now let's have a look at what we have
done
so first of all
once the player enters the digit the
value will go to the suitable if
condition
as you can see here the player will
enter the digit then the value will go
to this particular
suitable if condition
once the particular condition matches
then it goes to the below if condition
that is over here
here it is checked whether the space is
already filled or not if it is filled
then we will get the message that there
is no empty space
but if it is empty then the player can
fill the space with zero or cross
depending on the player
so now let's go ahead and create a
function
and we'll name this function
as
function 3 which is of boolean type
all right
here we have created this function of
boolean type because we have to return
true and false only in this function we
will set the condition for players to
win and check whether the game is still
going on or it is a draw
so let's start first of all we'll create
a for loop which i trades from
zero that is end i equals zero
i less than
three
till three and i plus plus
now
inside the for loop we will set the
conditions for a player to win the match
so as we know that in the game of tic
tac toe if the pair of three matches
whether it is horizontal vertical or
diagonal then that particular player
wins the match
so here we will set the conditions for
horizontal and vertical pairs and after
this we will set the condition for
diagonal pairs
so let's start
so we'll write f
at a space
space
i
will making
we are making
row
a variable
i zero
equals equals
space
i
one
space i1
and
space
zero again
equals to space
i
two
there's a mistake again
all right
so this condition is for first row as we
can see
so in the condition we are checking if
this element that means the element at
this position is equal to this position
and the element at this position is
equal to this position
then the particular player wins
and that's what we are doing in the
condition the loop starts from zero so
first zero zero
equal to zero one that is first and the
second element then first and the third
element
so it is checking that whether these
three elements are equal so if they are
equal then it is true and otherwise it
is false
so here we have checked horizontally and
now we have to check vertically so we'll
write
or
and we'll write
space
zero i
zero
i
equals
space 1i
and
space
zero i again
equals to
space
to
[Music]
i
here we are making
rows fixed and column variable
so if these conditions are true the
player wins
so we'll return
true
so now similarly we'll do for the
diagonal elements
for diagonal elements we have to check
diagonally so we don't have to use the
for loop we'll write space
zero
zero
equals
space
one one
and
space
1
1
equals space
2 2
now here are
space
0
2
equals space
1 1
and space
space
one one
equals
space
2 0
okay
so if these diagonal conditions also met
then
it is true that is it's a win
all right
okay so after
this so these were the conditions for
winning the game so now we have to
make the conditions to check whether the
game is still going on or is it finished
so we'll do that
so we'll write 4
and
i equal 0 i less than 3 because it is a
3 cross 3 matrix
and i plus plus
after that we'll write
for
end j or k whatsoever you want in j
equals 0 j less than
3
j
plus plus
all right
now inside this both of these for loop
we will write the condition of if
space
i
j
not equal to
[Music]
the symbol that is
cross
and it is also not equal to
this i
j
[Music]
also not equal to the other symbol that
is zero
then
we will return
false
so here what we are doing is in the if
condition one by one every position is
being checked we have written if the
value at the position is not cross and
is also not zero
that means the game isn't finished yet
or it is still going on because the game
is played till every position is filled
totally so if any position is not filled
that means the game is still going on
that is why we have returned false
so we have used these conditions
if the player wins the game
these were the conditions to check
whether the game is still going on now
only condition left is to check if the
game is draw
so
after this
if this condition is not met and this
condition is not met and this condition
is also not met then there is only one
possibility that the game is draw so
after this for loop the control will go
to outside the loop so we have to create
a variable
let's say tie
and make it true
so we also have to declare this variable
and the data type of this variable must
be boolean
so we can
write bool
tie
all right
now let's come back now after
it is tie we will return
false
all right
now we have created these three
functions that is function three
function
two
and function one
so now one by one we have to call each
and every function
starting from one two and three
systematically we'll do it so
write int main
all right and main inside into main
first of all we have to call these three
functions one by one so how can we do it
so we'll write
while
and inside the while loop we'll write
the condition
not
function
3
here it means this loop
will keep on iterating till this
function
will return false and this function that
is function 3 will keep on returning
false until
any player that is player 1 or player 2
wins the game
so if the game is not won by any of the
player then again these functions will
execute one by one
so this cycle will keep on repeating so
we'll write function one first of all
after that
function
two
and then function three
all right so after this while loop
will write if condition
if
token
equals symbol
x
tie
is false
i'll explain this part
now we'll write n1
that is the name of the player1
and after that we'll write
vince
then we'll write endl
similarly we'll do it for
the player 2
but we have to write in else f
token equals
symbol
0
and
tie is not there that is the game is not
tie
[Music]
then
player 2 wins that is n2
wins
now in the last
there is else block
so this block else block will execute if
the game is draw
so
it's
a draw
all right
we we have done a mistake over here
if the token value is x then
n2 wins
that is player 2
if the token value is 0
then n1 wins
so yes here if the value of tie is false
that is there is no tie between both the
players and the value of token is x that
means player 2 wins here the token equal
to x that is cross means that the last
turn was of player 2 and the game was
not a tie and is ended so it means the
game is won by player 2 and vice versa
for the player 1
and if both the conditions are not met
then it is a tie
so now let's try to run this let's save
it first
now let's try to run this
hope it works
there are some error
let's have a look at them
okay so we haven't used the brackets
plus there are some more errors
so let's fix them all
function two and function three
as you can see there are no brackets you
forgot to
mention the brackets
here as well
and for the strings
we have to do
like this
all right
there are some more errors
so let's do some changes
and we also forgot
to make it a character array
let's make all the elements as character
and also we have to assign tie
to something like let's say
false
we have to initialize it
and
let's see if there are some more errors
there must be some more errors let's
save and run it we forgot to save it
now we'll run it
okay
there are some more errors
we forgot
to put bracket over here and call the
function one
and let's just copy and paste
this whole enter the name thing into the
main function that's where it will look
nice and
it will minimize the errors so we can
copy this or we can cut this
and
we can paste it in the main function
all right
now
now let's save this and let's try to run
all right there are some more errors i
think
single quotes we have to make it double
quotes
all right plus i think
now let's try again
this is showing the error
all right this is 112
all right
after this we have to make some changes
in this
if if and
else statements
so so let's change this so we'll write
else if statement
and
write the condition
that
if digit is
less than 1
and
or
digit is
greater than
9
then this message that is invalid should
be displayed
all right now let's try to run this
save it
and run this
function1
now our only error is function1 so
function1
spelling is wrong
let's correct it save it
and now let's try to run this
okay
enter the name of the first player let's
say sam
entered the name of the second player
that's ron
here it is so
sam we forgot to
mention the space so that is why it is
coming along sam please enter
so let's say sam wants to enter at third
position
so here we can see
at third position
this is the third position and here it
is
the cross now ron please enter
we forgot to add the space so that is
why it is
looking weird but yeah
now
ron will enter let's say one
as you can see
zero is at place one
now
sam
will enter
six
as you can see
sam is going to make a pair on the other
side ron will now click on five
all right now
sam again will click on 9 to make his
pair
as you can see sam has made his pair and
sam wins
so this is the game of tic tac toe and i
know the code is pretty long but it is
worth trying and if you want to do it in
a better way then you must practice it
for like two to three times
so this is how you can create a game of
tic-tac-toe in c plus if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now we are planning to develop tic tac
toe in javascript so let's go and start
developing our next game that is called
tic tac toe
so in this tech tractor i will start
working with creating a folder called
tic tac and inside this i'm going to
create a new
file name called
index.html now here onwards the same
thing
i'll be creating this html tags
and now here onwards
we want our some classes for headers and
footer
but so we're going to create some div
tag now
so in this div tag
i'll be creating some of the tags
in which the css class will be applied
so we just gonna create a classes
i'm going to just use those classes but
we'll create it later on so just go
ahead and create those so we're saying
do
okay
so now this point onwards is my first
dev tag inside this i'll keep
my h1 tag
and under this h1 i will be offering
some of the headings which will be
useful
to contain some necessary information
with regards to this game so tip here we
say h1
and inside this h1 we give the message
called class
equal to header
and here i'll give the name call
is a tic-tac-toe game
after this div class
yeah here we will start working with our
form tag
within my form tag i will start my div
after div tag i will use
label
so label for player one
or else i can say player one and inside
this let's give the name called
player
one label is closed
and after this label we'll start working
with our input tag
input
now in this input what are the details i
need first i need call type equal to
text number one second
placeholder equal to enter name
next name
equal to player1
next we want id
equal to
player 1
and then
any class if i want to apply
anyways we're gonna close this this is
my first text box
and same thing i would like to create
for my another one
so the first dev type we have used let
me go and create another tip tag
in this div tag i'll use the same label
copy the same
paste it here and this is for player 2.
so we have this
two players with me and after this div
tag
i'll offer the submit button now
input typically submit
start game
now the form tag is closed here
dev tag is also closed
so
you want the div tag to be closed or
before that it's up to you now
so here we have a called div class
whichever we have taken so if you want
you can basically put it later or before
whatever
so we will basically form that with this
so form tag is there later on you can
just show some containers where the
details will be visible to me
so here after the form tag
let me try to offer but first check with
it is really working fine
so here
yeah we have this option called enter
name internet after the stick tag tool
so
yeah so here the details we have taken
input application text and input
typically text
okay so two values we are taking now and
accordingly we will go ahead now finally
after the form tag
we would like to start with working with
the tape tag again
div
and inside this div
i says i haven't created any css classes
so those we can use it little later on
but let's have
this div
and inside this step i would like to use
one more tip type
okay and here we want to use one more
div tag
so inside this div we will be using one
more div tag
so
in this div we can just give the value
called data id equal to zero
id equal to
zero it's just the value
we are passing it
div
data equal to 0 the div tag is getting
closed
fine so
that's how we want it now
so here the first div tag is closed like
that we can create another data id so 0
1 2 total number of 3 we want to create
it so i want to create 0 1 2 3 4 5 like
this
so the way we have created here
for this div let's go and create one
more div tag
id equal to
one
two
three options we have it now
okay like that i can keep on creating
the others also
too
three
four
five so zero one two three four five dot
number five we have created
one more i would like to create it down
here for six
there'll be no difference because we
haven't changed anything here
okay
so the div tag is getting closed here
okay
and
that's it
and if you want to create a some clear
border button that you can basically
offer it later on
but here
we can use one more tip
and here we see
dip classical to relative
and within this step tag i can use
any image tag if i want
so i just leave it as it is
and after this
i can create one more tip tag
and inside this another tip
okay
and
under this i'm going to create
a button
okay and in this button
we'll be having some value
okay
we can secure the volume called replay
this button is created and now we can
create a clear board
spam
and here is a clear board
that's it
okay so here
it's just
a small game i want to develop it
better
now there's no user interface has been
used so this user interface will be
using it later on by offering them a
pure
look and feel so that you know it gives
me
more better look when your application
will start
but most importantly i need to start
working with a javascript part where the
logic will get calculated here
okay so
we want to start with the javascript so
let's get included the javascript with
my code
so here
i can see here
a script tag
script
equal to
now the file i haven't created so let it
be as it is
that's it so this is my script tag and
let me try to include my
style cheat also so
i just say
link real quick style sheet
into the name called
css though i haven't created but i'm
giving it
okay
that's it
so we have taken
this html into our
consideration now we'll be creating this
css as well as the javascript to make
this example complete
well we are ready with our html but it's
time to basically go back and spend time
on our javascript we're going to create
a new file now with the name called
app.js
and inside this we will start writing
the logic with our main application
okay now the first thing is how we're
going to start now
yeah
so
first thing what we need to do is we
need to attach window
dot
add event listener
and when the window will load some logic
should happen so i'm saying load
second is the name of the function
so the name of the function perhaps does
not exist but i can give the name called
app
which i'm going to create it shortly
now here first of all let me try to
create a game board i'm saying let
gameboard
equal to now let me have some of the
values because it is
eight digit
so we just make it
like that
and one more
for making it nine
okay
so that's how
we're going to create it now
okay
now this is all empty right now
after that we're going to create let
turn
this new variable
equal to
zero
what this is it keep tracking if x or
zero player its turn
like which player turns it to b so just
it is trying to mention it i'm saying
let
winner equal to
false
okay now let's go and create the player
so
create
player how are you going to create a
player we say const
now inside this we can say name equal to
name
next we say return
name
that's it
okay after that i'm defining let
here
x equal to
player
with the empty value
and again
player
y
equal to
there is an empty value now let's try to
initialize the app
okay
initialize
now inside this initialize the app we're
going to create a new function
function
app
and inside this we're going to create a
variable likewise
input feed
equal to first of all
document dot
get element by id
here
we're gonna take
the
class name of this particular
text field so we are saying input
hyphen
field
okay
dot
focus
okay now after this we have to say const
add players
equal to once again
document
dot
get eleven by id let me just give the
name called player form
okay next we are saying
add
player
okay dot
add event listener we want to attach the
event
on which event
submit event
and what logic
add
players
okay
after that once the players are added we
are saying
let replay
replay button equal to once again
document
sorry
document part
get element by id or rather i will say
document.query selector
document. query selector
replay type
btl
okay
just the name we are basically taking
that and here we say
sorry
replay button
dot
add event listener
which even i want to say
click
okay that is the first event second
reset board
reset
board
that we are basically passing that
okay
now
this is the initial case which we have
it
now beyond that i will add
this is the layers what we have added
and right nut slides to add the players
so this is how we have initialized after
that let's
add
plates
how to basically add the players here we
have to just define the function
add
players
okay it will take
event as a parameter
and say event
dot
prevent
prevent default this present default
will try to prevent
the default
uh you know
behavior which is submitting to we get
avoided and now here we say if
this
dot
player one so we just define the
property called player one
if this dot player one dot what
value
okay
is
blank
okay or
just start
play two
sorry
let's start
player 2
now i just want to find it out its value
also
value
black
then what i should do
in this case i am saying alert
you
must
enter
name for
each
field
the user has to add the values and after
that
return
okay
now the next thing is like we would like
to select the players in this inside
this by saying cost
layer
form
container
again
const play from controller container
equal to
document
dot
query selector
talk about a query selector here we will
just pass
the value call
enter hyphen
okay now we say cost
boardman equal to
document
dot once again
query selected
dot
class list
dot class list dot
add here we're given the name forward
height container
class list
dot
remove
hide
hyphen container
okay so we basically taken that
and after this what i will do i'll just
say player
x
dot name
equal to
this dot
player 1
dot
value
ok this for player x copy this
player y
2
and after that
that's it so we have done it now
so
we'll be calling other functions one by
one but that is the first thing which we
have implemented
well so
add player function is added right now
and
after this add player we have to
basically call
one more that is called which returns
the current player so i'm saying return
current player
and here what i will do is we'll just
write function
and here we say
current
player and in this current player what
we will do is
we will say return
turn
just variable
okay percentile
2 we're just adding it with this
0. okay if it is
then
x
turn i'm telling you
okay or else
so we're adding like the current player
who says the current tail right now
well
after this adding the return current
player we're gonna add another function
that is known as call return the current
player return current player is having
this value and after that we need to say
resize the square in event browser is
resized
once again if the browser is getting
resized automatically the square size of
your
tic-tac-toe should also get increased so
we just say
resize
squares
and here we're gonna say this option
equal window
dot
add
event listener
now we have a call option called resize
here and the second parameter about your
passing is called on
resize
okay on resize
now let's try to add it
after this we are writing this function
called
function
on
resize that is a functioning for me the
one which we are passing into the second
parameter
we are saying let
all cells
equal
to
document
dot
query selector all
in this we are passing
board
underscore
cell
okay and then we're using another option
called what let
cell height
equal to
all cells
with the position
okay dot
of
set width
or
set width
after that we are saying all cells
dot
for each
here we are passing
cell
[Music]
and after that we are using cell
dot
style
dot
height
equal to now he'll be using this
backtick and use this
dollar sign and say
cell
height
and that to you know pixel
so this will be taking the dynamic
values
okay that's it that's it over
now we have to just launch our build
board
now
billboard
build
board so how we gonna build our board
now for this we are saying function
build port
and inside this billboard we will see
this option call let
reset
container equal to
document dot
once again query selected
and pass the value call dot reset
okay and after that we are saying
reset container dot
class list
dot remove
and we are passing the value call
reset hyphen
hidden
this value and after that
we may call some other type of functions
also
okay so for those functions i can say
first will be called on
resize
after that we are calling
add self click listener
but i do not have that function with me
these functions we need to create it by
our own
okay so we will just leave those for a
time being let's go back and create
another functions now so we just want to
write another event with self click
event for play to attempt to make move
so
here we're trying to say
cell
click
event
for
player 2
attempt
to make
move
now this function need to create it so
we just say function now
we just say function
and give the name of the function
to make move now
function make
move
it takes
give it as a parameter
and here we are saying console.log
and say enter
now let's go back and try to check
another condition that is called let
current cell
equal to
percent because you have to read the
value from there and here we are saying
what
event dot
current target
sorry
even dot
current target dot
first element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so we're reading these values
after that we use another variety called
it
sell to
add
token
now here we are typing document
dot query selector
and here
you know using backtick
i'm using this value called
data hyphen id
okay equal to
here we are using
once again in a single quotes
dollar
current cell
okay
so this value we are taking it like that
after that we are using this situation
called if
cell
to
add token dot
inner html
extraordinary mark
blank
once again if cell to add
token dot inner html
equal to blank
then what next
so cell to add token
dot inner html
equal to blank then what you should do
i'm saying console
dot
log
and give the value the one which you
want
okay
so
in this console.log what value we can
give it
cell to add token
we have it it is taking this value to
the current set dot inner html
console.log
and inside my console.log we can set
this
cell
is already
taken
so values are already taken for this and
now we will be
returning those values
after that we will be using else
condition
and here we use once again if
current player
okay
is x
then we'll be using this option called
cell
see we have this property option
available called send to active
consuming cell to add token
okay
dot text content
equal to
current player
okay and we say
game board
the one which you have created pass in
this game mode
this value call
current cell
and in this correct cell value will be
equal to
x
okay
else
we can say
send
to add token dot
text content equal to
current player
okay and say
game board
current cell
equal to
like this
okay so here we are adding the values
like that
so it is closed after that we can just
use the function name for
is winner to check whether the user is
winner or not so we are saying
is
winner
okay and
after that we are saying
turn
plus
after that we are saying
change
we do not have the function name called
change board header names okay so it's
just like that we're giving it so as
usual we can leave this function for a
time being
and we'll call this little later on so
leave it as a time
okay so your function is now ready
so the next thing what we need to check
whether
it is tie or not
okay so we are saying function
check
if
we're just checking the function
whether it is tie or not so here we say
if
the condition is turned
greater than 7
again
okay we can say give over first we can
say our time
okay
well after that we are saying winner
function
is winner
now what we will check is we'll check
const
willing sequences
winning sequences and here
sorry
here
we are having this array and having the
different conditions associated we say 0
1
2 probability we are checking it
and then i just copied
well using 0 1 2 and here is saying
and 0 3 6 again
0
3
6
and once again 1 4 7
4
7
and next we have a call two five eight
eight
then we are checking the value zero for
it
eight and one more last option we will
put is called two four six
six so these conditions we are adding it
now
after this array we can say
varying sequences start
for each
and give the name call winning combos
winning
combos
and inside this varying compound we are
giving let
cell 1 equal to
varying combos position 0
then
that copy
and paste three times
cell two
cell three
and here we get the other call what
[Music]
we are checking the condition
let's say
if
and here the conditions you are checking
what exactly that will be for the game
board using
game board
set
one
current player
sorry
current player
ampersand time percent
come down
game board
cell 2 and cell 3
and
cell 3
and
after that
we're starting the position
so after that
we're starting the position call
[Music]
by cutting this condition called
consense
const
sense
and then equal to
document dot
get element by or sorry document or
query selector
query selector
all
and here let's select the position dot
okay
then after that we will be using
cells
dot
for each
cell
and inside is what we are passing they
are saying
let
cell id equal to
cell dot
first
element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so this is the value which you are
basically adding it now and we're using
one more if condition
pressing if
cell id
now we're talking about call cell id
triple equal to
cell 1
or
cell id
cell 2
or
salary equal to
so three
okay and in that case we can use
cell dot
class list
dot
add
and get the name board
just give the class name
winner
so here we'll be giving the winner and a
part of that we can use the other
conditions too
okay so here it is
adding the value and now let's say
let
current player equal to
document dot
get element by id
so you can basically define it so
current player you want so we can use
the current player or whichever
conditions you want so here we use what
the cell winner
now
small change rather than using correct
player we can use
the current
layer text
the new variable we are creating it
current player text document dot rather
than saying getting event by id
you can say
query selector
and in this query selector will be given
the value
by saying dot board
player
hyphen turn
the value which we are giving it here
and that
query selector
value whichever you given this let me
try to put it in a
parenthesis
like this
okay now here we just check
if current player
x
then what
then in this case we can say
current player whatever the value we are
using current text dot
inner html
equal to
now we can define the value whichever
you want to
operate
we just use a condition called div
class equal to
okay so we are saying congratulations
okay and here you say
congratulations
along with
this dollar sign
and here we pass
player
dot
name
and here the tip tag is getting closed
like this
okay
so that's the message we are basically
printing it
and after that
we give this value
and say this message called
winner equal to
true
and after that
if you want to apply
remove
that function we haven't written
we'll be talking about a little later on
and just say return proof
so your function is ready now
and later on we can just check the
condition if filler
if
winner
or we can say
check
if
and
return false
that's it
now in our continuation to this example
we're gonna develop another function
which
the name is called change board header
names so let's continue by defining the
new function called function change
change
board header names
so this change board header names will
be the new function for us and here they
would like to check whether the user is
winner or not so here we say if
not
winner
then what
then in that case you have to say let
current player text equal to
document
dot
query selector in this we will be
getting the details like dot
or
and here we gonna give the name called
player
and hyphen turn
player hyphen turn
now later on after this particular
variable we have to just check the
condition by saying if
current player
equal to x if the position is x sorry
let me try to put it in capital letter
here
x
then we will say
current player
dot
inner html equal to
now here we have to just use the same
option called backticks because i want
to go multilines
that's the benefit of this backtick and
here we say in our inner html span
class
equal to
name
hyphen hyphen
style
close this and here
we want to use
the statement
now this
value
we want to write it with name attribute
so it is getting close and here we are
saying dollar
with this player
x
dot
name
and then
close the
span tag
and we say
you are
up
like this
and after that
we say div
class equal to
which is gonna create a class which
later on we can apply the css style on
the top of that u hyphen r hyphen
winner
and here we say closing the div tag
so dip tag is closed
that's it and now after this line
what next we have this called else
condition
else
what else here we say
current player
text
dot
inner html
inner html equal to
after this
we gonna write the span
class equal to here we say
name
hyphen hyphen same option we're going to
use it
so in this condition so
winner conditions so let me try to copy
the same rather than copying it again
and
again i'll just copy the whole text
expand class equal to
name hyphen iphone style player rather
than saying x you could use file
you are up you are
winner
okay so here it's getting closed
well after this what we need to do
create another function called resupport
function
reset board
now in this function reset board we just
say console.log
a small message
resetting
the resetting is added now afterwards we
will be using
the game board
and the same game board what we have
used it earlier
i'll be using the same conditions
on the top
if you remember that was the game code
for me so i'll be using the same
keyboard
they copy this
yeah
with the same condition
okay gamepad this after that line we
will say let
sell to add token
send to add token
equal to
document dot query selector all
here
in this i'll be using
another class called
letter
now
cell to add token
whichever we've used dot
for each
square
and within this square we would like to
use square
dot
text content
equal to
black
after that square
dot
parent element
dot
class list
dot
remove
and here you would like to say board
okay underscore underscore
cell
winner so these classes we had to create
because these changes classes were just
using this but we haven't created we'll
be using it a little later on
so that was the point
now after that we are defining the turn
value
turn
equal to zero because we are resetting
it n
winner equal to
false
after that winner equal to false we just
define another variable called define
let current player text
current player text equal to
document
dot
query selector all
yeah document query select all
so here
we're gonna use the name called board
define player hyphen hyphen turn
after that current player
current player
text
current player text dot
inner html equal to
once again we have to use the condition
for
up
and winner point so let me try to copy
this
inner html equal to
okay and in this we have to say player x
dot name
okay just everything is same
no change at all
okay now
here after that we're gonna write one
more function call function
add
cell
click
listener that means when i will be
adding
or clicking something to my cell
what kind of event i would like to
listen
here
we are saying const
cells equal to
document
dot
query selector all
let's check
the condition board
board
cell
and here once again we say cell stock
for each
dot
for each
and here this is cell
dot
add
event listener
which event i want to listen
click and the second parameter will be
handler
once called
make move
okay and this function which we have
created called add cell clicks listener
okay this i'll be calling it here
perfect
later on once it is done let's try to
add one more function called function
remove
cell
click
listener
remove cell click listener
now here we say
let
all
cells
equal to
document
dot
query selector all
let's pass
board
cell
and now we say
all cells
dot
for each
cell
and here we say send dot
remove
event listener
which event
click
and second parameter will be make
that's it so friends now here
most of our javascript code is written
now
so going forward we would like to use
css
and finally we'll be applying everything
into our html file
well after the javascript file is ready
towards my application now it's time to
go and create our html file now sorry
the css
so
inside my tic tac i have got app.js and
index.html ready now here i'm going to
create another file here called
app.css see you can basically put this
app.css in either folder like in static
folder but i have just kept it outside
now from this point onwards i would like
to start with my basic functionalities
okay what those are let's start with the
first feature called morning
with my body
some basic settings i would like to do
like in background image background
color so i just start with
background color
background color i can just use it as a
white
okay
but i don't think so it's really needed
it so if you want you can have it
otherwise leave this background because
it's by default going to be white only
and now
next would be called height
height will be 800 pixels
next background position
background position i just say like
center
next background repeat in case if you do
not want to repeat the image
background repeat
and here i say no repeat
next background size
they're using cover
okay so it resize the background image
to cover the entire container
okay so that's what the body part
now the next thing is we have to select
the
rest of the css classes so first select
div
dot relative
inside this data alternative is first
say call position
position we are saying absolute
next is stop
from the top i'm just making 760 pixels
next
right
right is saying 120 pixels
next
after this we are saying height
container
height
dot
container oh sorry hide hyphen container
here in hyphen container we will display
display
colon
none
well after that we have to use the
header point
header
inside the cell we will say color
will be by default white but still we
just say color
and
white
next text line
we just say center
next margin
margin will be 50 pixels
next font family
font family i'm selecting called
permanent marker
permanent
permanent marker
okay next class we are talking about
call interplayer that's called dot
enter
hyphen
players
and enter hyphen players are the same
color
will once again
we can use any other clear but we can
just use white or any color you want or
you can just use
hash
okay
margin
margin we are giving it's called zero
auto width
we're looking forward for 80
next texture line
center position
relative
now
next we are going forward for input
field
in this input field we just say border
border two pixels
solid
and black
next outline
outline none
i do not want any outline to be there
next padding
i can take four pixels
eight pixels
four pixels eight pixels now margin
we are saying zero
0 10 pixels
okay and finally
for pixels
after smashing you say font size
18 pixels
okay so that is your input field
next we are talking about something
called input field focus
input
field
okay colon
focus
now here
border
two pixels
solid
right
or any other color which you want to use
it
next
how you want your submit button to be so
i'm saying
dot
submit hyphen btn
border
2 pixels
solid
and black
adding
8 pixels
and again 8 pixels
font size
80 pixels
now with
250 pixels
followed by border radius
5 pixels
next your margin from top
let's take 10 pixels
after that background color
let's take
white only
okay
so this is the property
now going forward you can associate
with your submit button active and
submit button focus so we are saying dot
submit
hyphen
btn
colon
active
and
two options we are taking
followed by condition outline
outline
[Music]
next border
we're talking about two pixels
solid
and the color
red okay
so that's the one
and after that we like to use over
dot
submit hyphen button colon
over what you want
change the background color
to what
white
you can use white smoke
well
here we like to use a
dot
board
here we'd like to use player
hyphen
so these are the classes we were using
in our javascript we remember
and here we say color
color we're using once again
white or you can use this white smoke
whichever you want
so
well later on
text align
center margin
10 pixels
0
and 10 pixels
height
54 pixels
okay
so these are the properties initially we
have taken
okay so after this
turn let's go and start another classes
here i'm saying dot
name hyphen hyphen
style
and here we are seeing color
red
and then font size
22 pixels
well
now coming back to the another
properties now we're talking about a
next important called border container
called board container dot
board container here we define width
which is 40 pixels we are taking
or sorry 40 percent we can rather take
after that background colors
that we can say quadrat blue
okay
next margin
we're taking is zero
and
auto
after that font size
font size we are taking zero
next border
bottle we are taking 2 pixels
then solid
and then black
followed by
box shadow
you remember this worksheet is one of
the very very season
three popular property here we're
defining three pixels
three pixels
three pixels
zero pixels
and
rgb
we can talk about call black
okay so my
border color will be shading color will
be
black
after that we're offering this
board cell
dot
now in this board cell we are defining
width
now in this width we are using
calculation
ca lc and in this calculation we are
defining 100
okay divided by three
this calculation
after this
the next property will be display
display will be inline block
next font size
we're taking 40 pixels
well texture line
center border
we are taking
two pixels
solid
and
black
adding 20 pixels
vertical align
top
next font family
this formula can use permanent
permanent marker
okay
now
next option
a part of this
we have a call
your board circle
board
cell hyphen
winner
i would say rather hyphen
now
spelling wrong this has to be d
yeah for cell winner
let's make background color
red
okay
and
[Music]
later on just use
letter
now in this letter we just give the
color combination so color will be
white
next position
relative
top
fifty percent
next transform
translate y
to minus 50 percent
after that font family
we are making it once again permanent
marker
let me copy
okay
now
here next option will be called winner
container
here we're giving
winner
with dot
dot
winner hyphen
container okay so for this winner
container what are the values we want to
use it
that's you want to basically do it so
before there's been a container what i
would rather suggest is you can use dot
reset
texture line
center
margin
20 pixels are
that is for reset and now reset hidden
inside this reset heading we will set
display none
display
none
okay after this the replay button
it's yeah i'm going to talk about replay
button dot
replay hyphen
btn
and here width
we make it
to
25
okay
and followed by padding
10 pixels we take it from here
and 20 pixels
border
this bottle we are taking is called two
pixels
followed by solid
okay and black color
now later on
border radius
border radius we're taking 5 pixels
later on
outline
i'm saying none
after this outline we say letter spacing
now this letter spacing would be again 0
after that
text transform
this text track form value we are
talking about
uppercase
next font size
font size
we are taking 16 pixels
then margin top
margin top would be 12 pixels
then word
spacing that you are taking three pixels
followed by background color
this you are taking white as usual
so this is for your replay button
okay
now in a similar line we can also have
call dot
replay iphone btn
colon hover
followed by dot
replay hyphen
active
now apply the common style outline
we are making it null
then color
we are making this call white
then background color
will be black
okay
and
when it comes to the congratulations
so we'll be using this
dot
okay so this congratulations class will
be using font size
to what 24 pixels
and after this we are using this call
winner dot u
hyphen r
dot
winner
in this winner we will be taking
font size
okay that's 18 pixels
after that height
we are taking little pixels again
then line height
line height we are taking 18 pixels
and then
margin two
pixels and then zero
okay
that's it so
last but not least we would like to use
this
dot
replay
iphone btn
this i'm saying with 50
50
percent
so this is what my css file is all set
i know it was pretty lengthy but it is
required for this particular application
okay everyone so we are all ready with
our css also now it's time to go back to
our index.html file
and take care about the final finishing
touch
so we have this index.html file with us
and now
the css class which we were using it in
our application that is known as call
this
permanent marker this class is not by
default available so we have to include
this
using this external api so here where we
have a call css with us
before that
we want
link
so within this link we want our
variable name called href
equal to now we have to give the proper
location by saying
https colon double forward slash fonts
dot google apis
okay dot com
slash css
question mark
family
equal to
permanent plus
marker
okay so if you just copy this
into your browser
you will get to know
where exactly it is using
okay if i just copy and paste it
so i just need to say https before
yeah https
fonts
dot
google apis
dot com
slash oh spelling wrong
css family equal to permanent marker
that is the main url from where i can
take this kind of font so here
css so that's what i was cross verifying
it
well it's there we have included our css
also but in which class we need to use
that is an important now
js i also want to include it
so here
in my head tag only
i would like to include
script
src equal to
app.js
so here my script is actually loaded now
after that
if i just go back and check
the
final outcome of my code
which is index.html file
well it pretty much look like in basic
nothing else has started when we talk
about call start game
okay so it needs to start because there
is no css class are attached so i need
to attach those classes within my code
so here onwards we have to start with
offering those css classes so that at
least i can apply
those common behaviors to my application
okay like here we have a call
div
we haven't attached any class to this
after this body we have a call tip h1
class equal to header tic tac toe then
we have a call tab we have a call
body
uh
under this we have a call another dev
tag so
just imagine how many type of classes
are available one we have called tip
class equal to header
div class is closed again we have a call
one more div tag so like that multiple
css files are there where we have to
apply the new css class
to make it happen so now we have to just
go back and change our html and to apply
our main class
so this is what my final html which
looks like the same you can see we have
added
all those type of css classes which we
had that is called interplay
player form player container label
placeholder
and player container
and if you see all different type of
classes we have attached this to
okay because
here only my css class will get applied
and the javascript will apply those kind
of dynamic css based on certain
conditions so these css classes are
already there added inside your html
page
our app css is ready
also ready now let's go back and try to
reveal how it looks like him
awesome so it looks like pretty nice
tic-tac-toe is a game it is expecting
and it says start game it says you must
enter a name for each field validation
is working
let me try to add
two names and say start game awesome so
now you can see it is saying hey you are
up
now let me try to give the values
awesome now you can see
it's saying like hey you are a winner
great so guys congratulations on this
the first example of how the tac door
game is
used so it is a classical example of css
javascript and html together
all right guys with that we have come to
the end of this video if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up i hope
it really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here